i've just finished up with the arcade 25
official
launch party here in australia and even
though it was an online event this year
it was
definitely something to be excited about
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about archicad 25
the brand new
2021 edition it is the anniversary
edition it marks a quarter of a century
of archicad products that have come out
and we've celebrated across the years
the 25th edition
really does focus on do more be more
and do it together overall it is a
pretty major upgrade and we're going to
get into the little nitty gritties in a
minute
however for those of you just wondering
when it's coming out
archicad 25 is technically officially
available
but if you are my cat image subscriber
or a ci tools member here in australia
it's officially released on the 12th of
july
2021. many of the updates that they
showcased today
during the live launch event as well
will be coming
later on in the year they won't be
immediately rolled out without kid 25
which is a little bit disappointing but
you have to take
some good with the bad and know that
there's more good things coming on later
down the track so let's get right into
it with
brand new features arcade 25 and wrap it
up at the end with my personal
opinion of what you should do between
arcade 24 and arcade 25
if you have the ability to upgrade so
one of the first
and prominent features showcased in our
cad 25
was the upgrade of a selection tool
usually in a 3d window you would find a
3d object and you could select it
but then you'd have to go back into 2d
to find out where that was again
and you'd spend quite a bit of time
going between 2d 3d
just figuring out where these objects
are basically now what they've done
is provided a brand new selection tool
you click on one wall and you can
automatically find it in 3d
or if you're in 3d you can do vice versa
and you can automatically find it in 2d
to add to the mix of this you can also
hide your selections by right clicking
going down to hide selections and it
will automatically hide everything
that you've clicked on so this is
definitely going to be a useful feature
if you've got a wall in the way if
you've got an object in the way
or anything in the way that has really
been troubling you
in the past you don't have to turn off
layers you don't have to
mask things you don't have to delete
things it's just a lot easier now and
something that probably should have come
in
at a lot earlier stage archicad 25 has
focused a lot on
improving the updates in archicad 24.
personally speaking arcade 24 was a
major upgrade
archicad 25 is still a major upgrade but
i don't think they implemented as much
as they did in 24.
so one of the tools that i implemented
in 24 was the openings tool it allowed
you to create
pretty much any opening that you wanted
except you didn't actually have the
ability
to freely customize it now they've
introduced the polygonal opening tool
which basically allows you to cut any
shape that you want by using the opening
tool
there isn't much more to it it's a very
simple tool upgrade but it is definitely
going to be beneficial
to most users using our cad25 something
that i am actually genuinely excited
about and happy to see introduced into
archicad 25
is the photo realistic textures being
introduced into 2d
as well as 3d so previously you could
add textures and surfaces
to your materials and you could have a
brick wall shown as a brick wall in 3d
however when you convert it into 2d it
wouldn't be really showcasing
that majestic feel that you're probably
looking for you'd have to take
all your 2ds into photoshop implement
some textures over the top
and waste a little bit of time basically
in photoshop to do
what you can do now in archicad 25 by
simply changing a few settings here and
there
you can quickly reintroduce all of those
surface 3d textures into a 2d section or
a 2d internal elevation
that you can then showcase to your
clients it also lets you introduce
shadows and distance markers into these
sections and elevations
which makes it look even more realistic
now personally speaking
these textures probably aren't as good
as what you can do in photoshop
but for the simple fact that you can
create them and save yourself a
significant amount of time
it might just well be the quickest and
easiest way to do it for some projects
something i personally really enjoyed in
the arcade 24 upgrade
was the new architectural furniture
package now in arcade 25 they've taken
that to the next level and i'm really
happy to see that
because i'm very much over using the old
architectural furniture
the best thing about the new package is
it is mainly kitchen
and living room base so there is a whole
new suite of
cabinetry details i believe it's 21 new
cabinetry modules
that are brand new and fully parametric
that means you can adjust whatever you
want height width
length different door handles different
kick plates different
bench tops you can change whatever you
want very very quickly now obviously
archicad did have this previously
but they basically just expanded on it
in a much more significant
and really required way with the
furniture i kind of got the sense that
they were stealing a little bit from
ikea's furniture catalog
they have taken a lot of the popular
furniture you see from ikea
and kind of introduced it into archicad
which don't get me wrong is fantastic
because the furniture in arcade is
terrible
so the new introduction of this is
fantastic there's simple things like
futons that have been introduced and
different dining room tables and bean
bag chairs so
they're definitely moving more into this
designer trend and the younger market
more so than your traditional foxy very
old-school architectural furniture now
unlike arcade 24 they didn't focus
so much on bim and collaboration but
they have had some serious
upgrades i won't go into too much detail
into the bimcloud
because most of the features that they
showcased aren't actually available just
yet
for example they're going to be
introducing bimx onto the bimcloud so
you can automatically link your bimx
model
to the bimcloud fantastic but i can't
actually test it out showcase it and do
anything
until it's brought out an update later
on this year if you're using archicad
you're more than likely also running a
mac
operating system you'll be happy to know
that they've replaced the opengl
software with the new
metal framework theoretically meant to
be significantly quicker
and perform a lot better but
unfortunately it isn't something we can
test
fully just yet if you're a rhino user on
the other hand they've introduced
functionality and support for rhino 6
and 7
which means if you're using the ladybug
plugin for example and doing shadow or
energy analysis
you really now can import that data
directly into archicad
and really streamline your process so
much better than you ever could before
now one feature that they did showcase
and unfortunately state that it is
coming later this year
is the parametric shift moving over from
the current rendering software
to redshift now i've personally taken a
look into redshift in the past
it runs side by side with cinema 4d
fantastically and flawlessly
and it is exceptional so overall what
are my thoughts on arcade 25
well personally i've been using arcade
24 for the last 12 months ever since it
came out
it was a fantastic upgrade it was a huge
stepping stone from arcade 23
and even bigger stepping stone from
arcade 21 which
was the transition that i made so
archicad
24 versus arcade 25 is there enough of a
justifiable difference to upgrade
if you're having to pay the premium
which i think is a couple thousand
dollars to upgrade
i'm not entirely sure i'm not entirely
convinced
if you're running a large-scale firm and
you're constantly migrating
new projects across and you have a
libraries manager
and a template manager who's constantly
going to be able to spend some time on
this
to transition it from 24 to 25 yes
definitely you don't want to be left
behind and have your projects be out of
date however if you're a very small firm
a very niche firm
i'm not 100 convinced that there is
enough justifiable
upgrade features to take 24 to 25.
i don't think i'd personally be spending
the money to jump to 25
unless i had it if i did have the money
yes 100
i always recommend staying to the latest
software
and migrating your libraries across
migrating your templates across
because it's so much easier to migrate
from one upgrade than it is from
two and especially when you go past two
it's just a nightmare upgrading
templates and libraries
personally i will be upgrading to the
archicad 25 library
because it's going to save so much time
with the 3d
photorealistic renders and hatches that
are allowed
in 2d and sectional views now so this is
just going to be a time saver
for all sorts of statutory regulations
and requirements
so this is going to be a great addition
that couple thousand dollar investment
is going to save
so much time in the back end that it's
basically going to pay off the
investment very quickly
that one feature alone makes archicad 25
a justifiable upgrade in my opinion
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
i hope you got a good recap of the
arcade 25
launch event i will be reviewing it in
more detail when i get a decent amount
of time to actually sit down
and play with the software i don't want
to give you my opinion on the software
until i've actually
genuinely used it for at least a couple
weeks preferably a month or two
i think that video will be coming a
little bit later this year so if you do
want to see that or if you want to know
anything more about the mac side of
things
make sure you smash that subscribe
button make sure you hit the like button
as well to help this video with the
youtube algorithm
and because you guys wanted this video
to come out as quickly as possible
and as soon as this information was
available to me
it goes live asap as soon as i finish
editing it basically
unfortunately there will be no video on
monday as a result so
it will be one and a couple days till
you see me again
but that video is going to be great i've
already planned it out i've already
recorded most of it
and so far i do think you're going to
enjoy it and i'll see you
next next monday